il ya près de deux cent mille canadiens
qui ont reçu un diagnostic de cancer
l'année dernière chaque personne réagit
différemment à l'annonce de ce
diagnostic à l'hôpital maisonneuve
rosemont on s'est donné comme mission de
détecter le plus rapidement possible la
détresse qui prouvent les personnes qui
souffrent du cancer
michel rochon cécile mathurin est
infirmière auprès de patients atteints
de cancer un travail délicat qu'initie
de la compréhension et de la compassion
comment ça va aujourd'hui bien fou elle
rencontre ce matin sa patiente daniel
cloud atteinte de leucémie aiguë
lymphoblastique ensemble elles
participent à une étude en cours à
l'hôpital maisonneuve-rosemont pour
détecter par le biais d'un simple
questionnaire la détresse chez les
patients cancéreux
une approche qui l'a soulagé si cette
sera pas jugé parce qu'ils ont osé venir
à toi te demande et et animations plus
commode santé etc c'est un gros plus ça
nous aide énormément
une fois avoué est détectée cécile
matthieu rappez d'intervenir sur cette
détresse et offrir les soins appropriés
qu'elle fait de la premire par avance ça
la rassure et puis ça lui permettait
d'être un peu plus on maîtrise d'être
plus actrice dans ces fonds fait que
c'est un côté rassurant pour eux comme
pour nous puis quand il ya une confiance
qui s'installe entre une équipe un
patient va tout de suite on va beaucoup
plus loin plus vite ce projet d'étude
est un exemple des réalisations du
centre d'excellence en soins infirmiers
de maisonneuve-rosemont qui célèbre son
dixième anniversaire
l'objectif faire le transfert entre la
recherche et les soins
est-ce qu'on va améliorer la survie il
ya des études qui disent oui que
lorsqu'elle patient est capable de faire
tout ce traitement puis est capable
d'apprendre à gérer aussi
ces différents symptômes de détresse on
pourrait influencer sur la survie des
patients
mais c'est la compréhension dans le fond
le fait qu'on comprenne ce que je peux
vie un pas de plus vers une médecine de
compassion ici michel rochon radio
canada montréal